let's see if we can take the integral of
cosine of five x over e to the sine of
five x dx and there's a cross walking
outside of my window so i'll try to stay
focused so let's think about whether u
substitution might be appropriate your
first temptation might have said hey
maybe we let u
equal sine of 5x
and if u is equal to sine of 5x we have
something that's pretty close to du up
here let's verify that so du
could be equal to so d u dx
derivative of u with respect to x well
we just use the chain rule derivative of
5x is 5 times the derivative of sine of
5x with respect to 5x that's just going
to be cosine
of 5x if we want to write this in
differential form which is useful when
we do our u substitution we could say
that d u
is equal to 5
cosine
5 x when we look over here we don't have
quite d u there we have just cosine of
5x dx oh sorry i need cosine of 5x dx
just like that
so when you look over here you have a
cosine of 5x dx but we don't have a 5
cosine of 5x dx but we know how to solve
that we can multiply by
we can multiply by five and divide by
five one fifth times five is just going
to be one so we haven't changed the
value of the expression but when we do
it this way we see pretty clearly we
have our u
we have our u
and we have our d u our d u is five let
me circle that let me do that in that
blue color
is five cosine of five x
dx
so we can rewrite this entire expression
as
do that one-fifth in purple this is
going to be equal to one-fifth i hope
you don't hear that crow outside he's
getting quite obnoxious one-fifth times
the integral of all the stuff in blue is
my d u
all this stuff in blue is my
d u
and then that is over
e
to the u
so how do we take the anti-derivative of
this
well you might be tempted to well what
would you do here
well we're still not quite ready to
simply take the anti-derivative here if
i were to rewrite this i could rewrite
this as this is equal to
one-fifth
times
the integral of e to the negative u
e to the negative u
d u
e to the negative u d u
and so what might jump out at use maybe
we do another substitution we've already
used the letter u so maybe we'll use w
we'll do some w substitution and you
might be able to do this in your head
but we'll do w substitution just to make
a little bit clearer
so let's this would have been really
useful if this was just e to the u
because we know the anti-derivative of e
to the u is just e to the u so let's try
to get it in terms of the form of e to
the something not e to the negative
something
so let's set
let's say i'm running out of colors here
let's set w
let's set w is equal to negative u
in that case then d
w derivative of w with respect to u is
negative one
or if we were to write that statement in
differential form
d w is equal to d u times negative one
is negative
negative d u
so this right over here would be
our w and do we have a d w here
well we have just a d u we don't have a
negative d u there we can create a
negative d u by multiplying this inside
by negative 1 but then also multiplying
the outside by negative 1 negative 1
times negative 1 is positive 1 we
haven't changed the value we have to do
both of these in order for it to make
sense or i could do it like this so
negative 1 over here and a negative 1
right over there and if we do it in that
form
then
this negative 1 times d u that's the
same thing as negative d u
this
is this
right over here and so we can rewrite
our integral
it's going to be equal to now it's going
to be negative one-fifth
negative one-fifth
trying to use the colors as best as i
can
negative one-fifth times the indefinite
integral of e to the well instead of
negative u we can write w
e to the w
instead of d u times negative one or
negative d u we can write dw
d
dw
now this simplifies things a good bit we
know what the antiderivative of this is
in terms of w this is going to be equal
to
it is going to be equal to
negative one-fifth
negative
one-fifth
e to the w
and then we might have some constant
there so i'll just do a plus c
and now we just have to do all of our
unsubstituting
so we know that w is equal to negative u
so we could write that so this is equal
to
negative one-fifth i want to stay true
to my colors
negative
one-fifth
e
to the negative u
e to the negative u that's what w is
equal to
plus c we're still not done
un-substituting we know that u is equal
to sine of 5x
u is equal to sine of 5x so we can write
this as being equal to negative
one-fifth
negative
times
e
times e
to the
negative
u
which is negative u is sine
of five x and then finally we have our
we have our plus c
now there was a simpler way that we
could have done this by just doing one
substitution but then you would have
kind of had to look ahead a little bit
and realize that it would have been not
trivial to take your oil not too bad to
take your anti-derivative of e to the
negative u the insight that you might
have had although you shouldn't really
hold yourself feel too bad if you didn't
see that insight is that we could have
rewritten that an original integral
we could have written the original
integral let me rewrite its cosine
of 5x
over
e
e to the sine
of 5x
dx we could have written this entire
original integral as being equal to
cosine
of 5x times e to the negative
sine of 5x
dx
and in this situation we could have set
u to be equal to negative 5x and say
well if u is equal to or negative sine
of 5x if u is equal to negative sine of
5x
then du is going to be equal to negative
cosine
of 5x
and we don't have a negative 5 oh dx we
don't have a negative 5 here but we
could construct one by putting a
negative 5 there and then multiplying by
negative
one-fifth and then that would have
immediately simplified this integral
right over here to be equal to negative
one-fifth
times
times the integral of well we have our d
u
our d u let me do this in a different
color
we have our du that's the negative 5.
let me do it this way negative 5 cosine
of 5x dx negative 5 cosine of 5x dx so
that is our du i'm just changing the
order of multiplication
times e
times e to the u this whole thing now is
u this second time around
so if we did it this way with just one
substitution we could have immediately
gotten to the result that we wanted you
take the anti-derivative of this i'll do
it in one color now just because i think
you get the idea this is equal to
negative
one-fifth
e to the u
plus c
u is equal to negative five
negative sine of five x so this is equal
to negative one-fifth
e to the negative sine
of 5x
plus
c and you're done so this one is faster
it's simpler and over time you might
even start being able to do this in your
head
this top one you still didn't mess up by
just setting u equal to sine of 5x we
just had to do an extra substitution in
order to work it through all the way
and i was able to do this video despite
the crowing crow outside or squawking
crow